alles klar
die küche kann tödlich enden kann
ja hallo herzlich willkommen zu unserer
pressekonferenz heute mit annalena
baerbock und robert habeck und wir
freuen uns ihnen heute den entwurf für
unser programm zur bundestagswahl 2021
vorzustellen
wir haben ungefähr eine stunde zeit ihre
fragen stellen sie das kennen sie schon
bitte im chat ich rufe sie dann auf am
ende werde ich gegebenenfalls bündeln
wenn es zu viele fragen werden
und jetzt robert habeck beginnt vielen
dank und guten morgen von unserer seite
wir freuen uns über den nächsten streich
stehen wir ihnen heute vorstellen dürfen
aber lassen sie uns erst einmal mit
einem dunk beginnen so ein wahlprogramm
schreiben ja nicht nur zwei vorsitzende
sondern das ist ein breites teamwork
dass die partei insgesamt auszeichnet
und trägt deswegen einmal danke an alle
die beigetragen haben per arbeit per
ideen und per solidarität dieses große
gemeinschaftswerk heute vorlegen zu
können
wir haben ihnen vor noch nicht allzu
langer zeit das grundsatzprogramm
vorgestellt und dann beschlossen das
grundsatzprogramm legt das fundament auf
dem wir jetzt quasi mit dem programm für
die bundestagswahl 2021 ein neues haus
bauen wollen
es geht von den zielen zum konkreten zu
machen von der zielorientierung zur
projekt orientierung erlegen dieses
programm in einer zeit vor wo eine
politische ära zu ende geht wurde eine
neue beginnen kann
wir leben in einer phase des umbruchs
des politischen umbruchs in einer phase
von schwierigen politischen
entscheidungssituationen große
veränderungen sind nötig und große
veränderungen finden statt
große veränderungen führen aber häufig
zu großen verunsicherungen
viele menschen erleben im alltag die
dysfunktional i tät des staates sie tun
ihr möglichstes sie strengen sich über
gebühr an nach den regeln
beziehungsweise nach den notwendigkeiten
zu leben
auf der anderen seite erleben sie eine
politik die oft scheitern oder
widersprüchlich daherkommt der staat
wird manchmal als machtlos empfunden
das gilt nicht nur für die korona
pandemie sondern das gilt auch für die
großen herausforderungen der gegenwart
vor corona und es wird nach corona eine
andere politik notwendig sein müssen als
wir sie bisher gehabt haben stichwort
delta für wissenschaft und forschung
eine bildung auf der höhe der zeit mehr
ausgaben für die infrastruktur die
digitalisierung aber natürlich auch das
zentrale menschheitsthema unserer zeit
die erderwärmung so in den griff zu
bekommen dass ein leben in würde und
freiheit für die menschen auf diesem
planeten möglich ist die
regierungsparteien sind erlahmt und müde
nach all diesen jahren in der großen
koalition deutschland wirkt saturiert
müde wandlungs unlustig ja mittelmäßig
wir legen mit diesem
bundestagswahlprogramm vitamine vor eine
vitaminspritze für dieses land finden
sie auf den seiten bewegen gleich
vorstellen werden
wir gehen von den großen fragen unserer
zeit aus den herausforderungen die
bewältigt werden müssen der klimakrise
etwa dem vertrauen in die demokratie das
zu stärken der offenen gesellschaft
einen funktionierenden sozialstaat der
nächsten schritte der einigung für
europa mit diesem programm mit den
projekten in diesen programmen wegen wir
ein ambitioniertes aber an der realität
orientiertes programm vor dass wohlstand
freiheit neu begründen und neu sichern
soll
wir gehen pragmatisch vor
leidenschaftlich und optimistisch das
klingt selbstverständlich ist es aber
nicht dieses programm ist der abschied
von einer reaktiven politik die stets
nur reparieren will die dinge so lange
eskalieren lässt bis sie nicht mehr bis
ihnen nicht mehr auszuweichen ist wir
wollen mit diesem programm hingegen
einen neuen aufschwung schaffen
ein aufschwung der über das rein
ökonomische hinaus geht der mensch in
seiner würde und freiheit das war der
leitsatz für unser grundsatzprogrammen
dass wir im november beschlossen haben
diese würde und freiheit übersteigt die
dimension des ökonomischen die viel
mit einer gesellschaft ihr kultureller
reichtum die öffentlichen räume in denen
wir uns als menschen treffen können und
die wir jetzt zu sehr vermissen alles
das was im bruttoinlandsprodukt im web
nicht gemessen wird aber doch eigentlich
das leben erst lebenswert macht das hat
einen großen schweren fokus in diesem
programm
wir hoffen wir wissen wir wollen damit
die nächste phase eine nächste eine neue
politische ära einleiten deutschland
alles ist drin das ist der titel dieses
programms was wir heute vorlegen
deutschland alles ist drin spiegelt auch
unsere gewissheit wieder dass in diesem
land alle steckt was wir für die
bewältigung der großen großen
herausforderung der zukunft und der
gegenwart brauchen denn so viele
menschen das hat robert habe deutlich
gemacht so viele menschen haben in
dieser krise gezeigt was alles in uns
steckt so viele menschen sei es im
office in den altersheim in den
pflegeeinrichtungen in den supermärkten
in den firmen in den schulen und kitas
sind in diesem jahr über sich
hinausgewachsen und jetzt ist es an der
zeit dass politik endlich über sich
hinaus wächst gerade auch industrie und
unternehmen haben in den letzten jahren
erkannt dass eine vorausschauende
politik uns nicht in die zukunft führt
sondern sie haben deutlich gemacht
fordern deutlich ein dass die märkte der
zukunft klimaneutral sind und sie wissen
alle deutschland kann so viel mehr und
daher ist unser anspruch mit diesem
programm endlich politik auf die höhe
der zeit zu bringen
alles drin ist für uns ein weckruf dass
diese dekade wirklich ein jahrzehnt des
mutigen machens des gelingens und ein
jahrzehntes modernisierungs werden kann
dafür braucht es aber eine politik die
will
die nach vorne führt und vor allen
dingen in die zukunft verlässlich
steuert denn und das machen wir in
diesem programm sehr sehr deutlich wir
trauen den menschen in unserem land
etwas zu weil diese menschen in den
letzten jahren so deutlich gezeigt haben
was alles in unserem land drinsteckt mit
diesem programm machen wir ein sehr
umfassendes angebot an alt und jung mit
ganz konkreten ehrgeizigen projekten die
fundierte antworten in allen
lebensbereichen unserer gesellschaft
geben von der klima über die
wirtschaftspolitik zu einer starken
solidarität weiter zu bildung und
zusammenhalt und vor allen dingen
eingebettet in ein europäischen und
globalen kontext
und da die herausforderung unserer zeit
nur gemeinsam angegangen werden können
zieht sich gerade unsere europäische
haltung auch quer durch dieses programm
durch genauso wie unsere feministischer
haltung unsere projekte sind sehr
konkret weil es uns machen geht sie sind
ambitioniert sie laden aber vor allen
dingen auch ein mitzumachen und mit uns
gemeinsam die zukunft zu gestalten
wir schauen aufs ganze und haben einen
umfassenden inhaltlichen
führungsanspruch für die breite unserer
gesellschaft weil auch das ist in den
letzten monaten im letzten jahr ja so
deutlich geworden
es geht nicht um abstrakte ideen sondern
es geht um die lebensrealität von jedem
einzelnen in unserem land und daher
stellen wir auch sehr sehr stark in den
fokus was wichtig ist für den
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt nämlich
eine starke daseinsvorsorge gute schulen
und kitas gute gesundheitseinrichtungen
guter öffentlicher nahverkehr für alle
menschen in stadt in der stadt auf dem
land in nord und süd in ost und west und
wir bringen mit unserem programm
deutschland endlich auf den 1,5 grad
fahrt
das schaffen wir nur alle zusammen als
gemeinschaft insgesamt von den klima
schützen und klimaschützern die heute
wieder auf die straße gehen über die
stahl arbeiterin mit den pendlerinnen
und pendlern und daher definieren wir in
den projekten ganz konkret und ganz klar
wie wir ein klimagerechten wohlstand für
alle schaffen können
das heißt schneller kohleausstieg das
heißt aber auch transformation für die
beschäftigten die in den
unterschiedlichen branchen arbeiten und
das heißt eine unterstützung für die
region denn klimaschutz ist keine
zukunftsaufgabe klimaschutz ist jetzt
und klimaneutralität ist auf der anderen
seite die riesengroße chance für unsere
gesellschaft auf mehr lebensqualität und
der schlüssel dafür dass definieren wir
in diesem programm dann weiter ist eine
sozial ökologische marktwirtschaft die
den menschen in den mittelpunkt stellt
so wie wir es im grundsatzprogramm die
robert gesagt hat auch schon als
fundament gelegt haben und die zugleich
die weichen konsequent auf
klimaneutralität stellt und der
industrie der wirtschaft dem handwerk
den spielraum gibt die sie brauchen um
in dieses jahrzehnt von klimaneutralität
zukommen planungs sicher mit einem
klaren investitionsrahmen und zb quoten
für klimaneutrale produkte und das
definiert bei deutschland keine insel
alleine ist immer im europäischen
gemeinsamen binnenmarkt unser
handlungsort ist das gemeinsame europa
weil natürlich die frage auch der
wettbewerbsfähigkeit im globalen kontext
immer gegeben sein muss und klimaschutz
wirtschaftspolitik sozialpolitik und
alle anderen bereiche aus der
lebenswirklichkeit der menschen zu
definieren den mensch in den mittelpunkt
von unserer politik zu stellen
in würde und freiheit das ist der große
rote faden durch unser programm den
menschen im mittelpunkt zu sehen auf der
einen seite erfordert einen effektiven
staat auf der anderen seite ein
effektiver start ist einer der nicht von
der absicht her beurteilt wird und seine
projekte denkt sondern vom resultat her
und so ist das programm gehalten wir
wollen die wirklichkeit verändern und
uns nicht in abstrakten vorschriften
verlieren
insofern ist der gegensatz der die
politische debatte so häufig auf wie man
mehr staat oder weniger staat mehr
regeln oder weniger regeln
ein falscher und unfruchtbarer gegensatz
entscheidend ist wie sich die
wirklichkeit ändert und was dafür
notwendig ist das muss getan werden die
verschiedenen projekte die ausgaben für
klimaschutz
die investition in infrastruktur das
arbeiten für bildung und forschung die
ausgaben im sozialen bereich für eine
gute krankenhaus infrastruktur
beispielsweise sie kulminieren in einem
großen investitionsprogramm dass wir auf
liegen wollen es überschreitet die
investition die die bisherige
bundesregierung vor nimmt etwa um das
doppelte
die 50 milliarden die wir mehr ausgeben
wollen ist eine verdoppelung der
investition fast eine verdoppelung der
investitionen in deutschland und sie ist
dringend notwendig das reiche
deutschland investiert in seine zukunft
unterdurchschnittlich im europäischen
vergleich ganz zu schweigen davon von
den ländern die gesellschaftliche
wohlfahrt am stärksten nach vorne
bringen die skandinavischen länder aber
auch wenn sie schauen was in der usa in
japan los ist wir geben zu wenig geld
für unsere zukunft aus wir stellen also
der verschuldung in den büchern eine
verschuldung in der wirklichkeit
gegenüber die wir jetzt in der pandemie
aber insgesamt so stark gesehen haben
schlechtes internet schlechte schulen
beim wenig ausgaben in bildung und
forschung und zurück bleiben beim
klimaschutz all das läuft darauf hinaus
dass wir zu wenig investieren in unser
land in deutschland in die zukunft wir
wollen also die schuldenregel um eine
investitions regel ergänzen eine
vesti zions regel die festlegt dass die
öffentliche hand eine aufgabe hat die
die leben der menschen reicher und
besser macht eingeschlossen in die
ausgaben für die zukunft sind auch die
sozialpolitischen projekte günstiger
wohnraum eine erholung der innenstädte
ein lebenswert halten der innenstädte
investition in die
gesundheitsinfrastruktur die krankenhaus
infrastruktur kombiniert mit einer
reform der gelder für die krankenhäuser
der sogenannten fallpauschalen die wir
ergänzen wollen um eine vorsorge säule
so dass nicht alleine die ökonomie über
das gesundheitssystem bestimmt sondern
auch das bereithalten von kapazitäten
mitgedacht und mit belohnt wird wir
wollen einen bürgerfonds für die rente
auf liegen um altersarmut zu verhindern
und die menschen am wohlstand in diesem
lande besser zu beteiligen
so sehr wir über eine investitions regel
in der schuldenbremse die investition in
die infrastruktur bezahlen wollen so
sehr brauchen wir geld für den sozialen
ausgleich und zusammenhalt in unserem
land und dieses geld wollen wir holen
von denjenigen die ihre steuern nicht
bezahlen beziehungsweise der
steuerpflicht sich entziehen
der kampf gegen steuerhinterziehung das
austrocknen von steuersünden das
einhalten der regeln nimmt einen großen
schwerpunkt in diesem programm an
und der ist das lässt sich schwer mit
dem gelder die der gesellschaft zu
stehen bisher nicht akquiriert worden
das muss ein ende haben
ein effektiver staat bedeutet eine
undogmatische politik zu machen eine
politik die sich an der lösung der
probleme orientiert und nicht hinter den
vorschriften die entweder da sind oder
in zukunft erlassen werden versteckt das
bezieht an der stärkung der polizei und
der justiz mit ein
wir wollen die planungs beschleunigung
in deutschland voranbringen und in allen
bereichen die hälfte der bisherigen
planungszeiten erreichen bis zur
baureife dringen
mutig auch gerade für die
energiepolitischen projekte ausbau von
schienen von bahnen von stromnetzen
die ämter sollen digitalisiert werden
die bürger sollen über die
digitalisierung einen zugang zu
einfachen verwaltungs handlungen
bekommen so dass wir hinter einem
digitalen personalausweis oder einer
digitalen identitätsnummer einen
einfachen zugang zu allen behördengängen
haben ein staat der die sicherheit gibt
dass die dinge gut gehen dass die dass
das land funktioniert aber die menschen
dann im alltag in ruhe lässt
wir wollen den menschen etwas wir wollen
wir vertrauen den menschen aber wir
trauen ihnen auch etwas zu das programm
ist ambitioniert ist liegt die schritte
die nächsten schritte für den wandel
fest und beschreibt ihre umsetzung
ein effektiver start ist einer der auch
die kräfte der verwaltung freisetzt und
sich nicht hinter den strukturen der
verwaltung politisch versteckt die
kräfte der verwaltung setzt man frei in
dem man bereit ist politisch etwas zu
riskieren führung zu zeigen
politische führung ein anspruch mit
seiner person zu verkörpern und das
risiko des scheiterns auf sich zu nehmen
das ist die konsequenz aus all dem was
wir beschreiben und diesen
führungsanspruch unterstreichen wir mit
diesem programm und sie und ihr seht wie
viel leidenschaft und herzblut in
unseren gemeinsamen projekten hier drin
steckt aber es geht nicht nur um inhalte
sondern es geht in den nächsten vier
jahren auch im stil
es geht darum wie wir regieren und zwar
gemeinsam und daher wollen wir mit
diesem programm wollen wir mit unserer
leidenschaft mit den vielen vielen
projekten auch das angestaubte
verständnis von macht und politik
aufbrechen weil so viel in unserem land
drinsteckt und weil so viel da ist das
beste rausholen
es geht uns daher nicht um die
verwaltung des status quo sondern es
geht darum jetzt endlich die zukunft zu
gestalten und das kann man nur im team
das kann man nur gemeinsam uns beide
aber eigentlich unsere ganze partei mit
den vielen vielen neuen mitgliedern hat
in den letzten jahren vor allen dingen
die kooperation das gemeinsame
miteinander getragen
die herausforderung sind so riesig dass
das keiner alleine schaffen kann sondern
das geht nur gemeinsam in einem modernen
regieren aber auch in einer gesellschaft
die jeden und jede sieht und ein
gemeinsames wirtschaft daher ist dieses
programm nicht nur ein inhaltlicher
sollen den vor allen dingen auch ein
führender gesamt gestaltungsanspruch und
modernes regieren bedeutet für uns
konsequent europäisch zu handeln dass
immer nur zum rat hin gefahren wird und
geschaut wird was ist eigentlich das
beste aus nationaler sicht das bringt
uns als europäerinnen und europäer nicht
weiter das beste allein für uns ist
nicht unser maßstab sondern das beste
für europa denn nur wenn es europa gut
geht kann es auch deutschland gut gehen
und auf dieses gemeinsame
gesellschaftliche und europäische
miteinander zealand wir wir zielen auf
die mehrheitsfähigkeit und wir sind mit
diesem programm mit unserem verständnis
von modernen regieren gut vorbereitet
eine neue ära zu beginnen
berbalk und robert habeck
die erste frage kommt von frau vaters
vom handy
klimaschutz bewegungen bereits kritik
ihr programm sei im bereich klima co2
preis und so weiter zu unambitioniert
und falle hinter bisherigen beschlüssen
zurück können sie da noch was drauflegen
und die zweite frage sieht strich
darunter ziehen
was kostet ihr gesamtes programm und sie
haben die schuldenbremse steuer
steuern steuererhöhungen da drin und die
bekämpfung der steuerflucht vielleicht
können sie das mal ein bisschen
gegenrechnen
wie sie da dann sozusagen auf eine
vernünftige gegenfinanzierung kommen
wollen
wir haben mit blick auf ihre klimafrage
ein dreiklang in diesem programm einen
dreiklang an ordnungsrecht das heißt der
klare regeln zu setzen wie wir die
klimakrise in den einzelnen sektoren in
den griff bekommen das bedeutet zb ein
beschleunigter kohleausstieg 2030 das
bedeutet nur noch emissionsfreie autos
zuzulassen ab 2030 und vor allen dingen
den massiven ausbau von erneuerbaren
energien zu dem dreiklang gehört auch
dass preise die ökologische wahrheit
sagen dass diejenigen die auf
klimaneutralität umstellen nicht wie
bisher schlechter gestellt werden
sondern eine chance mit ihren produkten
wirklich auf dem markt haben das ist der
punkt den sie mit co2 bepreisung
angesprochen haben und der dritte punkt
ist für uns in diesem klimagerechten
dreiklang dass es vor allen dingen
starke investitionen gibt um die ganz
großen investitionen die notwendig sind
um die chemiebranche um das bauen um den
verkehr klimaneutral hinzubekommen auch
gemeinsam zu stemmen und daher sehr
große große passus auch zu insel den
investitionen wo robert habeck gleich
drauf eingehen wird wir glauben dass wir
nur mit diesem dreiklang klimagerechten
wohlstand für alle schaffen können weil
es geht eben uns darum nicht nur das
klima zu retten sondern für eine
solidarische gesellschaft zu streiten
und daher auf die frage warum wir nicht
den maximalen co2 preis hierfür uns
setzen weil wir überzeugt sind mit einem
preis allein schaffen wir nicht
klimagerechten wohlstand sondern fallen
einige hinten runter sondern es braucht
für klimagerechten wohlstand den
dreiklang zwischen einen starken und
ambitionierten ordnungsrecht zwischen
einer co2 bereisung und einer starken
innovation was die finanzierung angeht
so habe ich schon ausgeführt dass ein
großer schwerpunkt der investiven
bereich da ist deutschland gibt 2,45
prozent seines bips für investitionen
auch der europäische durchschnitt liegt
bei 3 die spitzen länder sind um 6%
unterwegs das sieht man über die jahre
sieht man es in der infrastruktur das
sind kreditfinanzierte durch eine
investitions regel in der schuldenbremse
hergeleitete investition in die zukunft
die dann jeder öffentliche euro so sagt
man wird durch 15 privaten euro bieten
oder lose 15 private investitionen auf
ein wirtschaftswachstum ein co2 armes
dann klimaneutrales wirtschaftswachstum
auslösen wird das also in sich selber
schlüssig der sogenannte konsumtiven
bereich der bereich der sozialausgaben
der natürlich auch in unserem programm
einen großen raum einnimmt also soziale
gerechtigkeit umverteilungs projekte ist
ungefähr mit 40 milliarden zu beantragen
für unser programm
die gegenfinanzierung muss sich ergeben
aus abbau von steuerlichen subventionen
die sind mit 50 milliarden im moment im
laufenden haushalt zu beantragen wie
wird man nicht auf einen schlag in einem
jahr abbauen können aber sicherlich in
einem großen teil sodass dort durch
streichung des jähnigen was wir
eigentlich gar nicht mehr wollen und gar
nicht mehr brauchen
gelder zu akquirieren sind und der kampf
gegen steuerdumping und
steuerhinterziehung wird ebenfalls
zweistellige milliarden beträge ergeben
können die stichworte sind verbot von
share deals anzeigepflicht gemeinsame
oder grund in eine gemeinsame
bemessungsgrundlage für
unternehmensbesteuerung country bekannte
reporting- also die verschiedenen
stichworte die da sind aber endlich
umgesetzt werden ernst zu machen mit
steuerdumping und steuerhinterziehung
gegen
kampf gegen steuerdumping man
steuerhinterziehung die nächste frage
kommt frau von frau joachim eine frage
von mir geht es zu ihrem ich muss jetzt
mal epo schnell vom wahlprogramm das ist
ja noch relativ ungewöhnlich das
schreiben sie dass sie eigentlich nichts
versprechen können dass sie eigentlich
wissen ob mich doch niemand durch
zimmerstutzen belastet wird sie nicht
versprechen könne noch genug geld da ist
nach der prognose
ich frage mich wollen sie damit
eigentlich die erwartung die jetzt schon
im vorfeld an sie sehr sehr hoch sind
wollen wir die schon grenzen weil sie
wissen müssen die am ende sowieso
enttäuschen müssen danke nein aber mit
dieser haltung die wir bisher hatten in
den letzten jahren alles wird schon
irgendwie gut kommen wir einfach nicht
weiter angesichts der grossen großen
herausforderungen wie die klima
angesichts der großen herausforderung
dass unsere gesellschaft noch mal
verstärkt durch die korona situation
auseinander bricht die einen werden
reicher die anderen werden immer ärmer
sondern dass wir uns wirklich anstrengen
müssen als politik dinge in zukunft
besser zu machen und daher kann man
nicht mit alten schablonen der
vergangenheit kommen und sagen das wird
schon irgendwie sondern wir haben hier
sehr sehr viele projekte drin wo wir
sagen da müssen wir uns auf machen auch
zu neuen ufern
und wie das so ist wenn man neue ideen
hat wenn man pragmatisch anpackt fall
ohne diesen pragmatismus kommt man nicht
voran das haben wir in den letzten jahr
sehr sehr deutlich gespürt dann kann es
auch sein dass man feststellt auf dem
weg des aufbruchs mensch wir hätten es
noch besser machen können wenn wir diese
eine maßnahme noch ein bisschen mehr
angeschafft hätten und daher ist für uns
ein zukunftsfähiges regieren ein
modernes regieren auch immer die
bereitschaft selbst kritisch zu
reflektieren war das jetzt das
allerbeste hätten wir es auch anders
machen können deswegen laden wir ein
unterschiedliche akteure zum beispiel
über formen wie bürger räte an diesem
prozess mitzumachen und haben eine
bereitschaft immer wieder auch zu sagen
der andere könnte vielleicht auch mal
recht haben wir reflektieren unsere
politik weil dieser
rettung des einer weiß alles und drückt
das durch das ist nicht unsere art von
modernen regieren das ist nicht so wie
wir in den letzten jahren gemeinsam im
team geführt haben und daher machen wir
im epilog sehr sehr deutlich wie wichtig
ist es uns ist auch immer selbst
kritisch zu reflektieren ob es noch ein
bisschen besser geht die nächste frage
kommt von frau jenen von bloomberg zu
europa und nord stream frau kennen ja
genau zwar fragen einmal im programm
sind natürlich auch jetzt viele
positionen die zum beispiel über einen
potenziellen koalitionspartner mit der
union hinaus gehen also und da auch
gewisse rote linien überschreiten und
dann nehme ich jetzt nun mal die
schuldenbremse
aber sicherlich auch die ausweitung des
ezb-rates oder auch co2 co2 preis
industrie könnten sie damals auch
beschreiben wieder ihre prioritäten sind
also weil es gibt natürlich auch
letztendlich darum koalitionsfähig zu
sein und dann die zweite frage wir haben
jetzt in dem programm nicht nord stream
erwähnt könnten sie da noch mal ihre
position erläutern insbesondere auch
weil in den usa derzeit erwägt wird
doch nochmal deutsche firmen auf die
sanktionsliste zu setzen
ich stehe die zu exterritorialen
sanktionen oder auch zu nutzen insgesamt
also das programm ist unser programm ein
grünes programm ein programm für unser
land und es ist nicht mit blick auf
koalitionspartner oder
koalitionsgespräche geschrieben sondern
mit blick auf die bedürfnisse und die
notwendigkeiten der wirklichkeit davon
leidet die sich ab natürlich entlang von
politischen leid kategorien unserem leid
kategorien
aber es ist kein kein schielen auf
irgendwelche partner sowie wir die ganze
zeit nicht uns von diesen ganzen
koalitionsdebatten irre machen lassen
wollen
für uns ist natürlich völlig klar dass
eine regierung die nicht auf dem paris
fahrt kommt die grünen nicht braucht der
klimaschutz muss umgesetzt werden sonst
sind wir da überflüssig in der regierung
die wege dahin sind
sind hier beschrieben wie sie möglich
sind und einer der hauptwege wäre der
beste weg deswegen haben wir ihnen so
hervorgehoben wäre in die zukunft zu
investieren nicht zurückzufallen hinter
anderen ländern hinter ganzen
kontinenten und dann für die menschen in
der wirklichkeit die verschuldung immer
größer werden zu lassen
schulen wo sich die fenster nicht öffnen
lassen sporthallen wo die kinder nicht
sich auf die toiletten trauen weil zu
sehr stinkt freibäder spielplätze
geschlossen werden all das ist auch
wirklichkeit in diesem land und die
klima infrastruktur neu aufzubauen haben
haben contract for difference is also
industrie verträge aufzulegen die co2
einsparung belohnen all das kostet geld
deswegen dieser große schwerpunkt wir
fühlen uns nicht alleine mit diesem
ansinnen
wir haben breite unterstützung aus der
wissenschaft ökonomie wir haben breite
unterstützung aus der wirtschaft die
danach sich sehnt dass wir diesen
aufschwung wieder möglich machen und
selbst das kanzleramt ist auf unserer
seite helge braun hat ja vor einigen
wochen bereits den vorstoß unternommen
und gesagt die schuldenbremse sowie wie
sie haben muss reformiert werden
die einzigen die sich an ihrer alten
ideologie festhalten sind diejenigen die
die zukunft nicht im blick halten und
zudem zwei frage doch noch den 2 taucht
auf einmal vorne in unserem klimaschutz
teil mit blick auf zukünftige
infrastruktur und zwar nicht nur diese
pipeline alleine sondern wenn wir
wirklich klimaneutral werden wollen
und das steht in paris drin das ist die
aufgabe unserer generation dann bringt
es nicht einfach nur zu sagen you alle
wollen klimaneutralität und irgendwie
kommen wir da mal hin dass es auch das
was zuvor gerade angesprochen wurde da
unterscheiden wir uns wirklich mit
diesem wahlprogramm von anderen vorlagen
die zum malen schon gegeben hat dass wir
sehr konkret sagen wie sind die
einzelnen schritte wie man es auch
machen kann und das heißt für uns zum
beispiel bei allen zukünftigen fossile
infrastruktur die jetzt noch geschaffen
wird als brücke
mit blick auf den kohle-ausstieg die
muss wasserstoff ready sein es kann
nicht sein dass wir dann in 20 30 jahren
wieder fossile konzerne raus kaufen
müssen sondern wir müssen jetzt dafür
sorgen dass wir wirklich die
klimaneutralität einschlagen und zwar
voll und ganz und das heißt dann auch
für most im 2 das ist nicht wasserstoff
ready das hat hohe geopolitische
probleme und es widerspricht den
europäischen klimaziele dass diese
leitung nicht fertiggestellt werden soll
und das machen wir in diesem programm
sehr deutlich so wie wir das in der
vergangenheit auch getan haben
frau wieder mal ja vom zdf ist die
nächste bitte ja hallo in die runde
schönen tag ich habe zwei fragen also
einmal sie haben ja ein sehr großes
investitionsprogramm vertrauen darauf
dass man dann die schuldenbremse lockern
oder möglicherweise gar auf jeden fall
was machen sie denn man braucht ja eine
breite mehrheit der schön parlament
erreicht der dann die
regierungskoalition nicht weil es eine
grundgesetzänderung braucht was machen
sie denn für den fall dass sie dafür
keine mehrheit kriegen wie wollen sie
dann ihre ganzen pläne finanzieren gibt
es dann möglicherweise doch noch höhere
steuern oder steuererhöhungen
abgesehen von dem was sie da jetzt drin
stehen haben und meine zweite frage habe
ich gestern abend auch schon mal gefragt
wo gab es den meisten streit wenn es
überhaupt streit gab was war der
umstrittenste punkt und wieviel
änderungsanträgen rechnen sie also wird
dieses programm ihrer meinung nach
wirklich so wie sie es jetzt vorgelegt
haben verabschiedet danke die
finanzierungsfrage betrifft alle
parteien wenn ich darauf hinweisen darf
dass das von der konservativen seite
hoch gehaltene zwei prozent ziel der
nato 15 milliarden extra für den
bundeshaushalt bedeuten würde
die abschaffung des soli ein loch des
verbleibenden solis in der spitze ein
loch von zehn milliarden reißen würde
versprechungen von steuersenkungen
schwer zu beziffern aber auch 15 bis 17
milliarden kosten würde
ist die frage der finanzierung eine
frage die sie in aller erster linie der
union stellen müssen
umgekehrt heißt es wir liegen ein
programm fest der qualität der
investition in wirklich zukunftsfähige
bereiche bildung forschung die soziale
infrastruktur die infrastruktur die
soziale gerechtigkeit schaffen geben
klimaneutralität das wiederum sind
gelder die den ländern und den kommunen
ebenfalls helfen
deswegen bin ich überzeugt davon dass
vernunft und rationalität und die
notwendigkeit die wir erkennen auch im
internationalen vergleich das wir
zurückfallen hinter anderen ländern
nationalität ideologie schlägt und es
ist ideologie sich nicht mit der
wirklichkeit zu beschäftigen
die wirklichkeit ist greifbar für die
menschen in diesem lande
wir haben niedrigste teilweise negative
zinsen wenn wir jetzt nicht investieren
ein wachstum auslösen dass sie dann die
kredite selbst wieder trägt und trägt
dann halten wir uns an etwas fest was
von der zeit überholt wurde und wir sind
voller zuversicht dass wir in der
breiten allianz die wir jetzt schon
spüren und von der wir wissen auch die
probleme die die anderen parteien damit
haben lösen können weil sie lösbar sind
und mit blick auf die frage der
diskussion
sie kennen uns grüne da steckt so viel
inhalt da steckt so viel leidenschaft
und vor allen dingen so viel mut zur
zukunft in diesem programm das wir
natürlich sehr sehr viel und intensiv
diskutiert haben gerade weil es darum
geht dinge nicht nur zu versprechen
sondern dinge umzusetzen konkret zu
sagen wie man es machen kann haben wir
im vorfeld dieses programmentwurfs sehr
sehr breit mit unterschiedlichen
akteuren der gesellschaft mit
expertinnen und experten aus industrie
und wirtschaft aus den umweltverbänden
aber aus den sozialverbänden mit
lehrerinnen und lehrern intensiv immer
wieder diskutiert wie können wir es
wirklich schaffen dass dinge in zukunft
besser laufen
daher kann man jetzt gar nicht eins raus
blicken und sagen da gab es an meisten
diskussionen weil manches mal im vorfeld
schon sehr intensiv diskutiert deswegen
werden wir mit blick auf die frage
auf ihre änderungsanträge das bei uns
bei uns grünen ja etwas anders als bei
anderen parteien
da könnt basismitglieder gemeinsam sehr
schnell änderungsanträge stellen
deswegen wird es sicherlich auch einige
geben
aber weil der vorab prozess so breit
aufgestellt war sowohl mit blick auf
zivilgesellschaftliche akteure als auch
innerhalb unserer partei sind wir sehr
sehr sicher dass das ein gerüst ist mit
dem wir bestens vorbereitet sind für
unseren parteitag aber daneben auch für
die zeit danach und ein großer großer
baustein den wir in der letzten phase
dann noch mal intensiv diskutiert haben
ist die frage einer humanitären
europäischen flüchtlingspolitik weil da
einfach in den letzten jahren
arbeitsverweigerung sowohl auf
europäischer ebene als auch national
leider betrieben worden ist wir haben
immer wieder sehr konkrete vorschläge
gemacht wie man dafür sorgen kann dass
man an den außengrenzen europas
gesicherte grenzen hat die aber auf
grundlage unserer menschenrechtlichen
verpflichtungen auch zugänge haben
deswegen sehen sie gerade in diesem
bereich ein sehr sehr konkreten
vorschlag wie eine europäische
flüchtlingspolitik zu gestalten ist und
da wir wissen dass auch europa kein
wünsch dir was ist und da dieses
versprechen was die letzte
bundesregierung immer gegeben hat wir
warten einfach ab bis sich alle einig
sind das können wir nicht sondern das
chaos an den außengrenzen die humanitäre
lage ist einfach fatal und deswegen
finden sie gerade in dem bereich einen
sehr dezidierten vorschlag wie man auch
mit unterschiedlichen europäischen
kräften dann über die form der
verstärkten zusammenarbeit hierfür
geordnete und vor allen dingen
humanitäre standards sorgen kann
vielen dank die nächste frage sehe ich
von frau höhne ist das richtig jetzt ja
okay ich habe erstens weiß ich fragen
haben sie die klimaneutralität im
programm sozusagen also diese maßnahmen
haben sie irgendwie prüfen lassen
wie können sie sichergehen dass sie
wirklich auf 70 prozent co2 reduktion
bis 2030 kommen und dann habe ich noch
eine frage zur parlamentsbeteiligung
wie stellen sie sich das vor wenn sie
tatsächlich ihr ziel erreichen sollten
und die richtlinienkompetenz im land
übernehmen wie soll das parlament
eingebunden werden soll das irgendwie
ein bisschen verändert werden oder nicht
an sie die ideen und die dritte frage
sie haben eine sehr konkrete fragen sie
bei uns ab sagt reformieren so dass zwei
mütter familien gleichgestellt sind mit
mit familien mit einem mann und einer
frau
und da wollte frank sprechen nur von
zwei mütter familien warum sollte es
nicht auch für zwei väter familien gehen
natürlich weiß ich dass das beim mütter
in deutschland verboten sind aber in
anderen ländern ja durchaus nicht
also beginnt mit der frage von
klimaneutralität da sehen sie auch dass
wir nicht uns an unseren eigenen
maßstäben messen sondern an den
herausforderungen unserer zeit und wir
haben in den letzten jahren nicht genug
getan beim klimaschutz weder in
deutschland noch europäisch die zahlen
die emissionen sind gesunken aufgrund
der pandemie aber nicht weil wir
wirklich den transformation schub
angegangen sind den wir eigentlich
bräuchte sind um auf den klimaneutralen
fahrt und auf den pfad von 1,5 grad zu
kommen
daher gibt es nicht nur auf europäischer
ebene ja ein neues klimaziel worum nach
wie vor weiter gerungen wird und wo die
deutsche bundesregierung insbesondere
die union nach wie vor die handbremse an
zieht auch in den trialog verhandlungen
und wir sagen wir können jetzt nicht
abwarten da gucken was in brüssel
passiert sondern deutschland ist auch
historisch einer der größten emission
wenn man das elitäre wenn man das pro
kopf berechnet und daher sagen wir für
uns bis 2030 müssen wir in deutschland
die emissionen um 70 prozent senken dass
es eine riesengroße kraftanstrengung und
deswegen unseres ganz ganz starke ansatz
das können wir als gesellschaft nur
gemeinsam schaffen das können wir nur
gemeinsam schaffen wenn wir alle
mit an bord holen und eben auf alle
bereiche genau schauen und ihre frage ob
wir das durchgerechnet haben also wir
machen ja klimaschutz nicht erst seit
gestern sondern das ist die dna unserer
partei
und natürlich haben wir auf alle
sektoren runter verteilt was 70 prozent
reduktion für deutschland insgesamt
bedeutet für den baubereich für den
verkehrsbereich für den energiebereich
jeder sektor muss auf klimaneutralität
umgestellt werden und auch da geht es
wieder nicht nur das wir zielzahlen
haben was jetzt zum beispiel im
klimaschutzgesetz der groko drin steht
sondern es braucht klare politische
instrumente auch klare
ordnungsrechtliche vorgaben da kann ich
nur noch mal unterstreichen was ich
vorhin gesagt hat das funktioniert nicht
allein mit einem co2 preis sondern wir
brauchen ein staates ordnungsrecht damit
unternehmen die sicherheit haben als
automobilhersteller zum beispiel dass
wir auch in zukunft deutsche hersteller
noch autos der zukunft produzieren
können hier am industriestandort
deutschland und da muss es eine ansage
von politik geben und unsere ansage ist
zum beispiel in diesem bereich ab 2030
nur noch emissionsfreie autos zuzulassen
und so können sie das einmal
durchdeklinieren durch alle anderen
sektoren wo jeder sektor sein beitrag
zur klimaneutralität leisten muss
was die letzte frage angeht ist der
grund die biologie künstliche
befruchtung geht nur bei lesbischen
paaren
also das ist der grund dafür bei der
familiären konstellation der
gleichstellung von familien
konzentration sprechen wir von allen
konstellationen die es gibt
frau hühner waren sie damit fein gab es
noch eine dritte parlaments frage und
die biologie würde ich in dem
zusammenhang irgendwie nicht so richtig
gelten lassen wollen weil
leihmutterschaft geht ja in holland zum
beispiel zur parlaments frage anderes
regieren bedeutet für uns nicht nur
anderes regieren aus einem kabinett
heraus auch da braucht es das gemeinsame
team hört wir sehen das jetzt ja dass
wir den großen herausforderungen dieser
zeit nicht gewachsen sind wenn gesagt
wird am besten übernimmt gar keiner
verantwortung wir verteilen große
zukunftsaufgaben für digitalisierung auf
so viele unterschiedliche häuser das
dann am ende keiner dafür verantwortlich
ist dass es mit dem glasfaserausbau
nicht hinkommt oder auch in der korona
situation dass der finanzminister dann
sagt der wirtschaftsminister schuld und
der wirtschaftsminister sagt der
finanzminister schuld und deswegen
kommen die korona hilfen nicht an dieses
verständnis von hier ist mein eigenes
silo und ich kümmere ich mich nur um
meinen kleinkram und ich gerne meinen
kabinettskollegen nichts das führt nicht
dazu dass wir die großen aufgaben
unserer zeit angehen können und es hilft
auch überhaupt nichts wenn regierung so
verstanden wird dass all das parlament
immer nur zum abnicken genutzt wird wir
haben das in den letzten jahren immer
wieder erlebt dass dann gesetzesvorlage
gekommen sind 48 stunden bevor der
deutsche bundestag entscheiden soll
gerne auch bei eg novellen gerne auch
bei maßnahmen im klimaschutz wo
vollkommen klar war
da stecken nicht nur fehler drin sondern
der steckten wirkliche fehlstellung drin
und deswegen heißt eben auch das
parlament als ort der politischen
debatte als austausch raum wo es ja
möglich ist mit blick in der diskussion
in den ausschüssen mit blick in
der diskussion mit der opposition auch
anzuerkennen dass das eine bereicherung
ist wenn unterschiedliche positionen
eingebracht werden und dass mal ein
änderungsantrag der opposition
anzunehmen das ist für mich keine
schwäche sondern das ist für mich eine
stärke und man sie zum beispiel im
europäischen parlament wie bereichernd
es sein kann wenn gerade angesetzten
eben unterschiedliche ideen von
unterschiedlichen akteuren eingebracht
werden und noch einmal ich habe das
leben schon ausgeführt dass es in dem
fall nicht gemeint die leihmutterschaft
sondern es geht darum die biologische
elternschaft dann rechtlich zu
ermöglichen
die nächste frage kommt von herrn rente
von deutschlandfunk bitte ich habe
einige fragen zur außen- und
sicherheitspolitik weil es jetzt noch
gar nicht zur sprache kamen und zwar
würde ich ganz gerne wissen die konkret
werden sie bei der positionierung
deutschlands im 3d effekte europa china
usa ich würde gerne wissen wenn sie das
drei prozent ziel klar ablehnen so wie
es formuliert es im programm wie sie
gleichzeitig dann das transatlantische
verhältnis stabilisieren wollen und zum
dritten schreiben sie zur ausstattung
der bundeswehr dass diese oder die
soldatinnen und soldaten sicher
ausgestattet und finanziert werden
sollen was heißt das so beim ersten
drüberfliegen habe ich zum beispiel den
zankapfel bewaffnete drohnen nicht
gefunden danke ja also genau wenn es auf
politische kapitel noch einmal
aufschlagen werden all diese themen
genau angesprochen damit dass jetzt kein
rein außenpolitische pressekonferenz
wird gebe ich mal so schlagworte sowohl
unser besonderes transatlantisches
verhältnis beschreiben wir ganz konkret
in einem projekt und vielleicht gleich
übergehend auf die frage 2 prozent an
dieser stelle für uns ist ein
transatlantisches verhältnis erstens
nicht deutsch amerikanisch sondern
europäisch amerikanisch geprägt und es
bezieht sich nicht allein auf
sicherheitspolitische fragen sondern wir
haben gerade in dem bereich von
klimaneutralität jetzt die krisen krise
große chance nach denen in den letzten
jahren ja leider die fragen auch von
handelspolitik mit drohungen betrieben
worden ist zwischen europa und zwischen
den usa ein markt für klimaneutrale
produkte zu schaffen und so eben diese
gemeinsame achse intensiv zu stärken
und ja transatlantisches verhältnis
bedeutet auch gemeinsame sicherheit im
transatlantischen raum aber ehrlich
gesagt habe ich die neue administration
von beiden und harris nicht so
wahrgenommen dass sie gesagt haben
wir schauen uns mal an was waren die
ideen der letzten 20 jahre und die
schreiben wir einfach fort und die idee
im sicherheitsbereich dem vor 20 jahren
war 2 prozent erhöhung im militärbereich
sondern dass gerade der anspruch der
neuen us administration ist sich den
neuen herausforderungen so zu stellen
dass man wirklich konkrete antworten
geben kann und unser vorschlag ist
gerade gerade da mit blick auf die
sicherheitslage in europa gemeinsam in
der nato strategisch zu definieren was
sind die neuen gefährdungslagen unserer
zeit zum beispiel cyber zum beispiel
automatisierte waffensysteme und auf
dieser grundlage einer strategischen
neuausrichtung der nato dann
festzustellen in welchen bereichen
braucht es mehr investitionen unser
vorschlag ist zum beispiel mit blick auf
ein gemeinsames cyber-abwehrzentrum dass
das eine aufgabe wäre wo auch
deutschland sich stark an also
engagieren könnte und den anderen
bereichen wo die gefährdungslagen
einfach nicht mehr da sind da muss man
dann auch nicht aus prinzip gelder
ausgeben und der dritte punkt der
wirklich anders ist als vor 20 jahren
zum glück haben wir europäer verstärkt
damit begonnen unsere fähigkeiten gerade
im sicherheitsbereich zu kühlen und zu
scheren sagt man auf englisch gemeinsam
zu bündeln weil es überhaupt gar keinen
sinn macht wenn 27 europäische staaten
oder die europäischen mitglieder der
nato alles doppelt machen sondern genau
deswegen haben wir ja eine europäische
kooperation auch eine deutsch
französische kooperation im bereich von
militär und sicherheit weil es nicht
sein
dass wir drei bis viermal so viel geld
ausgeben als europäer in der nato wie
russland und trotzdem weniger
fähigkeiten haben mit blick auf china
auch da gibt's kapitel zu es gibt ein
tapie kapitel auch nochmal auf die
besondere rolle von russland und unsere
haltung ist wir kommen nur als europäer
mit einer strategischen souveränität in
dieser neuen zeit wirklich stark voran
und deswegen heißt es nicht entscheiden
wir uns für die eine seite sondern
entscheide oder entscheiden wir uns für
die andere seite sondern es bedeutet für
uns selber in den bereichen zu
kooperieren wo es uns einen mehrwert
bringt und in den bereichen wo wir
strategisch auch selber souverän sein
müssen dann eben diese fähigkeiten auch
zu verstärken
vielen dank ich sehe im chat keine
weiteren fragen mehr
bleibt das so abfahrt ist sie haben noch
eine frage dann gerne los ja noch ganz
viele fragen finde ich aber ich würde
ganz gerne mal auf ostdeutschland
blicken und fragen ist stehen da auch
mehrere wahlen an diesem jahr
und die tun sich in ostdeutschland nach
wie vor erinnert schwer
was ist ihr wahlprogramms angebot
wahlprogramm an die bundesländer durch
das wahlprogramm team sich verschiedene
projekte die gerade in den ostdeutschen
bundesländern extrem wirksam werden
würden
der bereich von daseinsvorsorge im
ländlichen raum betrifft da vor allem
die strukturschwächeren regionen
ich habe schon im eingang statement auf
die krankenhausfinanzierung hingewiesen
die wir neu ordnen wollen neben dem
system der fallpauschalen das also jeden
fall wie der name sagt einzeln vergütet
und damit einen starken ökonomischen
anreiz schafft wollen wir eine zweite
säule schaffen die vorsorge mit mit
finanziell für blüten lässt so dass die
strukturen erhalten werden können dann
ein bisschen gestaffelt zwischen basis
und maximalversorger so dass es eine art
ordnungsprinzip gibt aber
die daseinsvorsorge im ländlichen raum
krankenhausbereich aufrechterhalten dass
es gibt weitere beispiele dafür wie man
durch kombinieren von synergien im
ländlichen raum strukturen schaffen kann
wir haben den bereich der lohngleichheit
oder lohnangleichung starke stellt sehr
viele menschen haben ja geringere löhne
in den ostdeutschen bundesländern da
gibt es umfängliche antworten darauf so
dass wir das land zwar als ganzes sehen
also nichts sektoren programme für den
norddeutschen den süddeutschen oder eben
den ostdeutschen raum oder die
ostdeutschen länder scheiben aber in den
programmen sich starke projekte finden
die gerade in den ostdeutschen
bundesländern wirksam werden würden
harris kopien von rtl hat eine frage und
er ist jedem raum dankeschön für platz
eins bei der bundestagswahl werden sie
unionswähler brauchen kriegen sie unsere
unionswähler mit einem tempolimit mit
einem aufweichen der schuldenbremse mit
einem ende des verbrennungsmotors
auch das unterscheidet uns vielleicht
von manch anderen ich hab gar nicht auf
welche richtung ich gucke dass wir gerne
noch mal die kamera
das unterscheidet uns auch von anderen
parteien dass wir jetzt nicht als
hauptaufgabe eines wahlprogramms sehen
strategisch zu analysieren was könnte
uns das bei den unions oder linken oder
wem auch immer wlan bringen sondern es
gibt große große herausforderung für
unser land die wir gemeinsam angehen und
meistern müssen vom klimaschutz von der
frage sozialer zusammenhalt
daseinsvorsorge in ländlichen räumen und
dafür machen wir angebote und wir haben
ja in baden württemberg gesehen dass das
unterstützung quer durch die
gesellschaft gibt quer durch alle
altersgruppen gibt und vor allen dingen
dieses verständnis dass eine gruppe nur
das eine und das beste für sich will
so erlebe ich ehrlich gesagt die
mehrheit in unserem land nicht
sonderschauen sehr sehr viele auch
ältere menschen was es gut für die
jugend was brauchen die eigentlich
genauso wie junge menschen in diesem
letzten jahr sicher sehr stark
solidarisch gezeigt haben damit wir
sicher und vor allem ältere menschen
sicher durch diese zeit kommen und
deswegen ist wie gesagt dieses programm
sind die einzelnen projekte ein angebot
für die breite der gesellschaft und
nicht für einzelne grüppchen oder
gruppen wenn ich ganz kurz ergänzen darf
unser wahlprogramm überschreitend unions
wählerinnen und wähler nämlich an wollen
anständige politik eine klare trennung
zwischen partei und staat sicherheit
nicht nur für die eigene tasche sondern
dienen am volke und nicht dient für sich
selbst
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass das
tempolimit die in verhunzten
konservatismus den wir im moment am werk
sehen irgendwie irritiert also dass die
menschen sich nicht genau anschauen mit
welcher haltung politik gibt betrieben
wird und was das programm ausstrahlt was
die projekte herleiten ist dass die
veränderung ein neues
sicherheitsversprechen gibt das ist
nicht auf unions wählerinnen und wähler
geschrieben das ist für die gesellschaft
geschrieben
aber die union musste erstmal bei sich
selber aufräumen
vielen dank robert habeck annalena
baerbock ich sehe keine weiteren fragen
im chat auch nicht die hier im raum
ich danke ihnen dass sie da waren
wünsche einen schönen tag und ein gutes
wochenende auf bald vielen dank alles
gute